oh yeah somehow Japan is the aside from
my home country the easiest place I have
to uh get away with the name I have
normally people would just look at my
name and just start having a panic
attack so Japanese people get it right
yeah cuz it's Mano which is like all you
know Japanese Katakana sounds I've
started booking restaurants under a
Japanese name cuz I'm so tired of like
who are
you I want to know which surname you
decided to Beck uh what name what Le
name have you decided to pick I I just
chose
Tanaka because I realized I realized
especially especially when uh cuz
sometimes I would call up and when I
would say my everything would be going
smoothly I'd be like I want to reserve
you we got an opening I got this and
then I'd be like oh here's my name
they're like huh it's just like an
awkward like five minutes I'm like I'm
just going to say this [__] name and
then want I turn up cuz it doesn't
matter there's no iding I just say this
I just find it [__] hilarious that
you book under Mr Tanaka and then you
rock up to the [__] restaurant you're
like uh oh they always they always go
like
huh yeah same with me so it's fine trust
me this I I know this sounds bad but it
works it genuinely works that's a good
idea I'll be T especially if you call if
you if you're calling it definitely
helps cuz like you can I feel like I'm
I'm nailing this conversation it's going
perfect they get to the name I'm like
yeah they're
like for a while I just kept saying
Conan like k k CU I was like oh they'll
know that I'd say Conor and they like K
and they're like I don't know I don't
know the [__] know this guy saying your
name is so simple though yeah I I know
I'd be like Kanan they're like like
Kanan oh oh
con I know
Conan you know in Japan you have to be
so specific when you write down the name
for the bank
oh I had to read out my entire name
middle name like Felix Arvid ol
over the phone no no you have to do it
the last name first yeah first name then
middle yeah it makes no [__] sense
but that was a nightmare to spell out
over the phone that's the worst thing
ever and of course it was wrong so they
call again and have to do the whole
[__] thing again it's not my [__]
problem you I was like I just email it
to you and they're like no well no that
was the worst part cuz one time I had a
fraud detection thing call up I was
sending myself money uh and they were
like we need to make sure it's not fraud
I was like why like it says my name but
they do you K yeah yeah and he was like
you know uh he he was speaking English
to me it was It was kind of to the point
where I was like I think I think I think
my Japanese which is bad is better than
his English like that he's like you know
LLY Russia
bad and I was like what do you you
always say that my banker said it too no
way really he was like fraud must check
I was like Russia bad I was like what
are you like I'm not Russian what are
you talking about I I got no Russian any
so uh and then he's like what's your
email and so and I'm reading out this
email to him and it's like a N9 hour
process of me going c b d and he's like
D no no [__] Z he's like what this like
no and then we get to the end and then
it's do at UK because I'm UK and he's
like I don't know the [__] that is I
put.com
no through all of it yeah some of my
official documents on some bills that I
pay are just have misspellings as well
like my my inst and I've haven't gotten
it changed yet because I've been putting
it off even though I definitely should
get it changed verying you uh but yeah
my do do do do foreign immigrants have
this problem when they come to the like
UK or America they're like ah [__] I
misspell my name from Brian to Bryant do
you know what I don't understand you're
Bob now Brian's too hard do you know I
don't understand so on my Internet bill
so when I signed up for my internet I
had to spell my name spell it again but
also there was this process where I had
to scan my ID card and send it to them
for them to like you know
I am a real and I'm like there is
absolutely no way I could [__] they
could [__] this up and I get my Internet
bill back and it still to this day says
Grant I do not know how they [__] that
up they they they're in on it they're in
on it like just like and I can't be
bothered to change it as well cuz it was
like such a you you you know when you
have like to change of name it's just a
5 minute process turned into an hour
long oh no no there's there is a [__]
five minute process in Japan nothing is
a 5minute process it's it's [__]
annoying that's the worst part for sure
so that's you know so I think you're
fully acclimated now you just need to do
a little bit more yeah if you can relate
to all these know the pain mean you had
your bank like close your bank account
as your Visa is renewing have you had
that happen no so the bank will send
every time I'm about to my Vis they'll
be like hey your Vis coming they don't
it they freeze it right they freeze it
but the thing is is that the bastards
they freeze it before your visas run out
they'll freeze it like a few days before
which I think is so [__] cruel yeah
why do they do this at least free okay I
can understand if you freeze it when it
expir I'm like okay I get it you want to
you want to [__] be strict on this
law I got it you're right but a few days
before come on man I still got [__]
going I still got time why you leaving
the last minute to get your I I'm not
but sometimes what happens is that what
happened last time is that uh when I was
renewing my Visa they um the immigration
just said we like like hey we want like
another month to go over we just want to
[__] with you a little bit yeah I was
like we went another month and I was
like what but my bank so so the I had to
go to my bank and like explain and it
was like an hour and a half thing where
I'm like no I'm definitely getting it I
promise but I have this thing in my
password that says I'm here for another
month so can you let me have it and
they're like they go back they always go
they always go back and forth with the
manager and it's like what is it can you
just come over here and help me with
this please come on man I'm I'm trying
to do stuff today the manager cannot
talk to Mere
peasants I must go through someone
that's my that's the worst thing I think
about Japan and like service industry is
that when when you have a problem you
can't just talk to someone who knows the
ansers they always have to keep going
back and forth with someone who knows
it's like so why so why do they freeze
it like the reason I think it's I'm not
sure I think the UK doesn't close it
immediately I think there there's a
window I'm not sure I think it's some
kind of their justification of like you
know you've lost your Visa you you know
we don't want to well a great man once
said Russia bad must check for fraud
yeah maybe that's they'll call me up
I'll be like why is it frozen he's like
Russia
bad that's all I got to say that's
literally what he said I I just remember
being on the train platform waiting and
he's in my ear says that and I just
burst out laughing I'm like no way he
just said that it's probably how we
sound like in Japanese I sound way worse
Russ
uh let's see what's
this yeah it's yeah we we get treated
with the we get treated with the the
past crimes and the fraud frauders yeah
I do for being foreign one thing uh one
thing I wanted to ask uh which is
something that I guess I've thought
about uh which is you know when I when I
eventually decide to be a dad now with
trash he's thinking about it now with
trash taste now of trash taste there is
just so much content on me out there and
it's always going to be out there and I
what are you implying no okay how you
how do you feel what are you actually
trying to say okay okay Bon comes in
he's like d what is apology
video did Dad do bad to
me you
w why was that the first video you out
of the thousands of videos I have I try
to block all of it no because I think
YouTubers are getting to that point now
where there I think there are some
Youtubers with kids that are getting old
enough to have started to become old
enough to really watch and understand
because there's never been a I don't I
think the oldest YouTuber kids I can
think of that like were growing up after
the YouTube and all that stuff I think
like I don't know like pH to Franco or
something I don't know also it's just
weird to me because you think about you
know think about your own parents and
you have no kind of bearing of what they
were like when no [__] clue yeah yeah
yeah you hear stories and it's almost
like alien you hear a story from like an
aunt or an uncle about how oh your your
parents were like this and you're like
this that's that's that's a fake person
it's actually smart though cuz you're
pre-loading like you know those iPad
kids it's like yeah my kid's an iPad kid
but he only watches
dad he's i' I've curated a playlist of
the greatest hits to babysit to babysit
my son it's not weird he watches only me
that's pretty good actually would that
be psychopatic you could probably you
could probably convince your kid long
enough to be like no no this is Dad
talking to something to boy also because
it's like you get the ad R for it's just
culating it's going in the F son my kid
is making me so much B from just
watching my playlist Al also you can
never discipline your kid for playing
too many video games ever again cuz they
could just they could just like they
just load up the receips being like
I calculated how many hours you know
okay okay uh just while cuz I'm going to
forget if I don't say this remember that
one time well I don't remember the last
podcast I brought up that you sang Take
On Me Yeah in in Sweden we did it three
two one which walk
away I don't know what say I'll
anyway today another day to find you sh
away
oh we did it yeah oh my [__] God I
told you not to no it was great show in
Sweden we did a
Justice on me front of the it was great
it was great it was great it was great
yeah it was great is there in any cringe
compilations how can I see this no it
was in the epic win compilations by fail
army so was mine so was mine no it
wasn't I son's going to see be like it's
a it's a fun song to sing it was it
wasn't the same cuz there wasn't like
the shot of just the crowd having the
Thousand Islands there they didn't
dirty that was that was the first Ninja
moment you know when he's like why we
I'm not seeing enough Movement we don't
need to bring up this will not see these
videos that will not be in the cured
playlist yeah whenever VI something bad
and you like scolding him you'll just be
like don't test me I have the
receipt just pull the iPad I just
realize yeah there's too much well I
mean I think it's fun too like we're
that'll be really fun I think yeah cool
and we're doing the Vlogs now like I
didn't have any videos of me as a kid so
I have no idea what it was like so I
think it would be fun to to watch that
kind of stuff yeah for sure yeah because
the the you did you have those like
family photo books when you were growing
up oh totally yeah and there you could
you could kind of figure out roughly
what was going on but it feels so feels
so cool looking at like just a still of
of yeah watch those forever I have a
shitload of like family videos cuz my
really I I didn't have any it' be so
cool I kind of wish that like I think
it'd be so cool for my kid to see me
like 20 just doing my thing that be SI
it's painful to watch yeah but it'd be
cool dude I'd love to see my dad doing
his thing that' be so sick like I I kind
of feel like that secondhand
embarrassment of like damn I was cringe
as [__] like when whenever I look at
some of these these videos cuz I'm just
like N I wouldn't I I wouldn't say that
like I think you know you you you'll
like you know if you have a good
relationship with your dad you'll love
your dad and you'll be like man it's so
[__] cool just seeing my dad hold no
my my parents use it to roast the [__]
out of me there are two types of memory
keeping want to to [__] someone over
whenever whenever my dad puts on like a
family video of me and my sister and
like you know I'm like like 4 years old
5 years old that's just cute yeah no
like my mom is sitting there being like
oh look at you you're so cute my dad's
like no look at you your balls haven't
dropped yet your little
[__] bro bro he's roasting a [__] how
old are you roasting a toddler bro on
fight back why is he roasting toddlers
son you sound like a squirrel puberty at
four your dad your dad was 100% the kind
of dad that when you all started doing
like sports he was like [__] Joey
[__] why you winning [__] you piece
of [__] yeah it's like you lost that's
cringe that's the dad I strive to be oh
my like the one family uh video I
remember is like my dad trying to like
my dad taking me to and my parents
taking me to the playground yeah and my
mom just lets me play around and stuff
and my dad's like the [__] the
[__] grind set guy he's like I get on
the monkey bars and I give up halfway
and he's like go in it again really he's
like we don't quit in this house go in
again don't don't quit halfway through
and I go on it again give up and he's
like no I'm going to pick you up and
you're going to learn how to do these
monkey balls oh really yeah that's cute
that's awesome yeah do you find that
helpful too young to say I was too young
okay but I just mean in General trying
to understand what's the good
parenting youal scen
please I feel like letting them learn a
little bit on their own is a good way
because I remember I one of the reasons
why I how long how old were you guys
when you learned how to ride a bike I
was six think I just unlocked a memory I
remember I don't
remember being in my driveway and doing
it when I was like I feel like I taugh
myself I don't remember really oh [__]
did you ever have like the training
wheel phase or I yeah of course yeah
[__] tore it up yeah so like my when
my dad tried to teach me how to ride a
bike uh he just completely skipped the
training wheel stage he was just like he
was just like get
good is
a it was like son you just got to grind
it out if you fall over don't worry just
get up and just [__] [__] the wheels
off the parent goes with the kid right
so they're holding it in case they're
like yeah my my dad used to like like
hold the back of the bike and then he'd
be like all right I'm going to let go
and I'm like Dad please don't and when
he do it anyway and then yeah i' get
fall you fall and then you get hurt you
cry you try again and then eventually
you do it yeah I think that's his Asian
Dad I an Asian
D I think my parents were just like
please stop cuz I just kept doing dumb
[__] I used to like you know I see a bum
and I'm like I'm going to
jump no I was I was too much of a [__]
to do stuff like that I just had no
sense of fear as a kid and then I got it
when I fell really badly one time and I
was like 15 everyone's going to learn
somehow I was like oh [__] this is scary
[__] around and found out this is
[__] scary like it really [__]
hurt Christ yeah that's that's how all
those Red Bull [__] athlete people
become those crazy people they just like
they just they just don't get they just
don't get hurt for a long enough of a
time until they're an adult and then
they they they can't learn it now
they're like
I'll break my arm or they're like oh
well it didn't kill me so I guess I'll I
can do it again yeah those Red Bull
sponsorships pay too good I can't turn
back now I got to do the free running
championship in the sling